there are countless reasons to get hyped
up for spider-man far from home there's
the web slinging action the
International setting and getting to see
what comes next in the MCU after
Avengers endgame but if you think that
the excitement subs on the final shots
are far from home fades to black you're
sorely mistaken we can confirm that
there's a surprise cameo included in a
mid-credits scene that will make
longtime spider-man fans totally freak
out it goes without saying that we're
going to get into major spoilers for
spider-man far from home from this point
on those hoping to walk into theaters
with a clear head and no context turn
away everyone else stick with us as we
reveal the epic cameo the mid-credits
team takes Peter at MJ back to New York
City where a news report plays out on a
huge screen to a crowd of bystanders
it's up on that screen that fans will
see a familiar face none other than the
Daily Bugle founder Jay jonah Jameson
what's even better about this cameo is
that it isn't just any actor playing
Jameson in the spider-man far from home
mid-credits scene
it's JK Simmons who famously portrayed
the crazed newsmen and director Sam
Raimi's original spider-man a film
trilogy from the 2000s Simmons last
sported Jameson's signature toothbrush
mustache and flattop haircut in 2007
spider-man 3 meaning his cameo
appearance and far from home it's the
first time in over a decade that he's a
sued in the role for a live-action
project in true Jameson fashion the
Daily Bugle blowhard isn't a huge huff
over spider-man's antics and the far
from home mid-credits scene the news
report includes an exclusive clip
originally released by the controversial
news websites the Daily Bugle net which
shows Peter giving orders to quote
execute them all this is obviously
doctored as we know spider-man would
never do such a thing still many New
Yorkers take it at face value
believing that the former friendly
neighborhood hero was the one who
orchestrated the attack on London the
events of spider-man far from home
revealed the actual perpetrator and it
definitely isn't Spidey Jameson pushes a
contrasting narrative that spider-man is
a menace and the villain are far from
home is really a hero who is spider-man
he's a criminal that's who he is a
vigilante a public menace many fans
speculated the spider-man far from home
would include a cameo from Jay jonah
Jameson with some outlets even running
early reports that it was definitely
true though it was difficult to prove
the claims at the time we can now say
with certainty that they were accurate
even without any leaks and rumors and
theories there was a big piece of
evidence
yesterday jonah Jameson cameo in
spider-man far from home
Simmons attendance at the film's well
premiere in Hollywood on Wednesday June
26th considering Simmons wasn't on the
red carpet for the premiere of
spider-man homecoming because he wasn't
in that movie Marvel super fans began
putting two and two together
Simmons Jameson would probably be in far
from home in some capacity turns out
they were right though the j jonah
Jameson cameo and far from home is sure
to make audiences scream and shout in
their seats it's only the start of the
after credits fun far from home also
includes a post-credits scene that
confirms a popular theory fans have
discussed for months on end we won't
spoil it for you here but anyone who has
seen Captain Marvel and speculated that
a certain element from that superhero
flick might pop up and far from home
will go nuts over the film's post
credits finger look forward to seeing J
jonah Jameson and spider-man far from
home when the film swings into theaters
on July 2nd check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about spider-man far from home
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]